[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see then what's
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire lovely to see both of you
um real made strange of newspapers let's
uh kick off with the front pages
reacting to the news that contrary to
what he said at the time boris johnson
did order the evacuation of animals from
afghanistan the star pitches a tombstone
with the words here lies the prime
minister's credibility and lies and lies
and so on as you can read for yourself
same story then the guardian has the
headline pm accused of lying over rescue
of animals during fall of kabul
published should be damned that's the
headline on the front of the eye
referring to the prime minister still
waiting on the report into downing
street parties by sue gray
the metro leading with prince andrew
insisting he wants a jury trial in the
civil case brought against him by
virginia dufrese she claims they had sex
when she was 17 an allegation that he
strenuously denies
and the express with the same story 2
andrew shock i want jury trial
a report by the commons treasury select
committee is expected to warn that
increasing national insurance will drive
up prices in shops that's according to
the telegraph and the financial times
reporting that the european central bank
has urged lenders that have dealings
with russian banks to be cautious in
case moscow decides to invade ukraine
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
or our guests who are andropius kevin
mcguire of course let's bring you in
lots of different leads it has to be
said so let's try and rattle through all
of them andrew kick off with the daily
express andrew shock i want jury trial
well this is huge actually because it
means prince andrew is determined to
clear his name there's been an awful lot
of speculation it's but we've reported
it in the daily mail that prince andrew
may seek a settlement at a court
settlement which would mean he would
never get to clear his name his name
would be tarnished it would be mud or
ever because it means he would the the
arguments would never be ventilated in
court he'd never be cross-examined he'd
never be able to his league lawyers
would never be able to challenge
virginia due phrase so this shows he
really is determined to fight it and i
suspect that it underlines why the queen
prince charles and prince william
intervened very recently and removed him
of all his last military patronages his
charity patron his and said he can no
longer call himself hrh he is still hrh
but formerly well he'll be known as
prince andrew and he'll be fighting this
on his own so this is gonna if he gets
the jury in the in the civil trial uh
it'll be an absolutely huge event now i
don't know when it will be remember this
is the queen's platinum jubilee year
there's never been one of these in
britain's history before uh on february
the 6th she'll have been queen for 70
years big celebrations in june we
already know that wayward grandson of
hers prince andrew sorry prince harry is
planning to write a book which is meant
to be coming out this year that will
cause all sorts of problems for the
monarchy uh if andrew's case goes to
court this year that will overshadow her
jubilee year too but the queen would
want him to clear his name i suppose
if he can and it's going to be
fascinating yes suggestion of late
summer should it come to that metro also
leading in this andrew it's trial by
jury they have pointed out to us that
this is the same language used in the
early court uh statements written by
virginia g frey's team
and uh it does not necessarily mean that
it will come to trial by jury well over
90 of cases civil cases rather in
america are settled um so i suppose it
means he's not folding rather than he
will proceed to a trial
i think i think i know it means he's
changed his his tactics uh because it's
a civil rather than the criminal trial
we wouldn't see him in the dark manic
old uh wearing a guantanamo beer style
orange jumpsuit he could be there if he
gives a evidence in person in a suit and
tie or maybe he could try and do it by
video link but remember he tried to get
the case struck out trying to hide
behind a dodgy deal struck by sex
offender
friend uh epstein but he that didn't
when that didn't work he's now gone on
the offensive here demanding uh the
trial by jury which looks like he's
engaging looks like he's been very open
but as you uh suggest it doesn't mean
behind the scenes there may not be
efforts to actually strike a deal but
this is the real royal scandal isn't it
there's been much attention on harry and
megan but that's a completely different
case
this is the scandal and he's played it
badly every step of the way because he's
looked very
uh evasive and i know he denies all the
charges
should emphasize that but nevertheless
he's looked as if he's been running and
trying to hide and here i think he's
trying to appear that he's he's far more
open but
wouldn't it be brilliant to see him in
the dark well i have to say as well
he'll have to take some serious advice
if he is to go into some form of witness
box whether i think it would probably be
by video links they don't think he'll
want to go into the united states in
case some guy somebody gets the idea of
arresting him although there's been no
criminal charges of any description but
his interview on newsnite was so awful
he was so high-handed and pompous he's
going to have to have really proper
training so that he comes over in the
witness box of sincere genuine and has
some compassion for jeffrey epstein's
victims of which there were many yeah
maybe
virginia goof ray's team could hire
emily maitlis to uh pose the questions
she did a very good job on news night no
he he would be a liability in the dock
in truth wouldn't he
yes well that's
we're still a long way from this stop
just don't buy it yeah we're still a
long way from this actually coming to
trial by jury and he of course denies
all the allegations against him um but
we're keeping an honor obviously through
the summer through the winter but moving
on to the guardian number of the
newspapers leading on the latest woes of
the prime minister and the issue of
whether or not he intervened
to prioritize animals over people the
denial of course was that uh this was
the end the u.s dictated when the end of
people could be evacuated from kabul uh
when the taliban took over and then
these animals got out penfold these
animals got out so where do you stand on
this one then andrew
well um i look it there there's two
emails come out of the foreign affairs
select committee from foreign office
officials saying the prime minister had
authorized it but it's not specific we
don't know who he authorized i heard
jacob rees-mogg the leader of the
commons um very robustly denying on
channel 4 saying look people pray and
aid the prime minister's name all the
time the prime minister's absolutely
clear he did not authorize this so um
but we're going to have to have more
clarity here because these two emails do
suggest well they stay they are foreign
office officials saying the prime
minister has authorized it it's not
explicit who he authorized how he
authorized it and he did say only last
week i think the prime minister i didn't
get involved now the suspicion always
was because his wife is a great animal
lover gary johnson uh that she that she
was involved but um ben wallace the
defense secretary was adamant yesterday
uh when he gave evidence to the select
committee that the prime minister at no
time told him to uh prioritize these
animals and it would be appalling if
animals were prioritized over people but
if i recall this correctly anna you'll
correct me i'm sure the plane that penn
farthing used to get those animals out
would not have had any people on it
anyway well it was chartered you know
that was that was the point it wasn't it
was charted privately and actually ben
wallace the defense secretary has come
out even more strongly saying the
evacuation of kabul under operation
pitting was run under my authority and
delivered by the uk military through the
joint uh the chief of joint operations
at no point were he or i directed by the
prime minister to evacuate penn farthing
his workforce or his pets as i made
clear at the time we were not going to
put pets before people and as the
actions showed penn farthing left last
and his workforce had to leave after the
evacuation was concluded via other means
um
but you know it it piles on pressure
again i suppose doesn't it that's the
point
it does i wonder how much that uh
directed by the prime minister directed
says ben wallace comes into play because
i i remember the reports at the time
that ben wallace the defense secretary
was exasperated by the pressure being
put on him to get was it 94 straight
dogs and 68 straight cats out of
afghanistan when there were hundreds of
thousands of people with allegiances to
to britain who'd work for britain uh
fearing for their lives were clamoring
to to to get out
uh and it really wasn't the fact that
maybe people wouldn't have been on that
plane it was the amount of time and
energy and effort that went into
processing all the uh all the details
around it when in fact they that cooked
time and that energy could have been
used to get people out but it's it's a
bad time for uh johnson this because
he's uh he's unreliable uh witness and
uh i think jacob rees-mogg's support
isn't very good for anybody at the
moment particularly the prime minister
that's jacob rees-mogg let's never
forget who wrongly uh advised the queen
to unlawfully suspend uh parliament with
the uh
where wasn't he his best movement and
he's now just the the chief apologist
and he would say anything to uh to help
the old prime prime minister right now
rubbish the scottish tory little really
like is it in a doc he'd be an
unreliable witness uh jacob rees-mogg
i don't i think that's unfair to say he
would he would do anything to support
the prime minister he was quite clear
quite expensive
he said he said he said it's not true he
said the prime minister did not do this
and ben wallace who i think is a hugely
respected figure and had it had a and
has had had a pretty good afghanistan uh
he was adamant that there was no
pressure on him whatsoever from the
prime minister let's just see let's just
kevin let's just see the story if we can
as well which is which is this sort of
relationship that boris johnson has to
the truth it's what it's what they're
alluding to here um but do you mind if
we move on so do you want to squeeze in
the national insurance on the front page
of the telegraph and the point being
that the sort of the current weakness of
the prime minister has allowed people to
put pressure on what to do about
national insurance and the telegraph
reporting that the commons treasury
committee has said that the planned
increase in april risks driving up
inflation as the country grapples with
the cost of living crisis so yet more
evidence about the difficulty of this
and what happens next
yeah an anarch will because that 1.25
increase is on employers as well as
employees that's how it raises 12
billion pounds inflation's uh
tipped to go up to seven percent uh and
uh the national insurance rise will
power that through rising prices as well
as leaving people with less money in
their paid packets and household budgets
the daily mail has a story that some mps
are saying to johnson you cancel the
national insurance rise and we'll back
you instead of trying to get rid of you
as prime minister he's weakened he's
weakened so everybody will want to be
doing their bidding but i would have
thought suspending that national
insurance rise if not cancelling it
would be good politics and economics
quick quick 10 seconds from andrew yeah
well i just want to say my newspaper has
been campaigning very hard that this
rise is completely unnecessary and we've
just seen borrowing figures coming
13 billion pounds lower than expected
that is exactly that would pay for the
12 billion pounds this national
insurance rise would generate we don't
want to see it postponed we want to see
it cancelled thori government should not
be raising national insurers at any time
let alone at a time when we're facing
across the living practice and i'm
pretty confident it's going to go
macro maths you've got to love it
haven't you amazing big numbers there uh
coming up though british troops are
understood to be poised to deploy to
eastern europe we will discuss that next
[Music]
well welcome back to watching the press
preview with me now andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire let's head to the story of
ukraine the suggestion of trying to
bolster the eastern flank of nato uh
including kevin with british troops uh
which is in a number of newspapers
yeah and the telegraph are reporting it
and say hundreds
hundreds not thousands or tens of
thousands hundreds of british troops go
to other eastern european uh countries
in nato not ukraine itself when there's
more than a hundred thousand russian
troops uh massed over the border of
ukraine in russia itself and belarus
with hundreds of british troops going
elsewhere really make much difference i
suppose you could argue it would deter
putin from going far wider but i'm not
sure it will deter him in invading
ukraine if that is his intention
meanwhile the diplomacy continues
political advisors from russia ukraine
france and germany
have all met eight hours of talks we
understand the us has delivered this
letter a response to sort of russia's
demands and so
where it goes from here uh is one thing
but the ft
links it also to a business the european
central bank warning lenders with
significant russian exposure to ready
themselves for the
imposition of international sanctions
against moscow and they're talking about
mega sanctions aren't they this time
andrew
really big sanctions to really [ __ ]
russia and also to stop them using
various international payment systems
which will
impact banks very quickly fortunately
none of the banks mentioned in the ft
are british banks but there would be
quite a lot of european banks in the
eurozone really affected
because look russia is a major player in
the energy field uh and uh and that
where there's already fears that there
could be power cuts across europe
because uh gas
putin could switch off gas supplies the
price of gas will go through even
further we'll go even higher and it's
pretty it's astronomical already and and
i do i chuckle when i read that story
about the diplomatic efforts going on
there's many different the only person
who's going to decide if the russia is
going to invade ukraine is the gangster
vladimir putin he doesn't give a fig
about diplomacy he does things his own
way he's an absolute dictator and i
think he my fear is he's boxed himself
in they will have to engage in some form
of military action to save face back
home andrew we've already seen this week
the volatility of russian stocks and
currency in fact so uh we watch we wait
we see what happens with there but both
thank you very much indeed andrew kevin
thank you weather now